this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
before we begin I would like to take an
opportunity to introduce carissa little
Carissa little is the director for the
professional programs at the Stanford
center for professional development she
has been with Stanford University for 10
years she is responsible for
collaborating with Stanford faculty
industry experts and corporate partners
to develop their professional and
executive programs that extends Stanford
to industry
she worked in both software and
education prior to coming to Stanford
welcome Carissa thank you Susie at this
time I'd like to introduce today's
presenter dr. mark char mark works for
the Center for design research at
Stanford he is a member of the symbiotic
project and effects neuroscience lab or
span lab at Stanford he is a lecturer in
the School of Engineering Mark's area
for research is in the intersection of
design thinking and the neuroscience of
choice where he has several research
projects underway mark comes to us for
30 years career in industry as a vice
president with the Procter & Gamble
Company and senior vice president and
chief marketing officer with intuit here
in Silicon Valley please welcome mark
char to our webinar series I'm you to me
well hi there I am now I'm on let me see
if I can get my slides kewda here we go
and as Stacey mentioned my background is
a long period of industry with Procter
and Gamble and Intuit where we spent
time conceiving of and then ultimately
delivering projects into the marketplace
today I have an academic career I work
in the center for design research here
at Stanford as well as in the span lab
which is an effective neuroscience lab
and what we're studying is choices how
people choose how they decide and how
that affects design when you think about
design you it's not unreasonable to do
exactly what's shown in this cartoon
which is if you just give me the recipe
if you give
the cookbook approach to innovative
thinking I'll do it
but that's what's so difficult about
design thinking is that there is no
cookbook there is no recipe behind that
yet we do know we can decode what's part
of design thinking and begin to
understand at least from a neurological
basis as we break it apart if you think
about what happens in industry today and
we use this as a definition for
innovation an idea occurs but it isn't
really valuable until you turn it into a
commercial product that can be sold
profitably now there are lots of ways to
do that and I think everybody's familiar
with the concept of stage-gate which is
a identified way of stepping from idea
to a commercialized project sort of step
by step and we start off with the best
intentions but more often than we would
like what ends up coming out the other
end is not it doesn't meet the the goals
and objectives we set forward so we look
at this and say how can that process be
amended how can it be approved and what
role can are learning in neuroscience
play in that area this is the rough
prototypical process map if you will for
design thinking as my friend bill
Burnett says it's not written in stone
it's written on a PowerPoint and it is
subject to change but this is how we
think about design thinking which begins
with empathizing what a potential
customer may want or need defining the
project ID aiding developing prototypes
and then ultimately testing those
prototypes
there is iteration built in every step
of this where you iterate within a step
and then ultimately between steps and as
we look at this from a neuroscience
point of view there really three
behaviors going on here the first one is
a framing behavior the second one is
risk and understanding risk and the
difference between risk and ambiguity
and a third is choice and how you choose
how you make one selection over another
that is the thinking behind design
thinking if you step back and say what
is neuroscience learning about the way
in which human beings think
it's broadly recognized that people have
two systems of thought which are which
are artfully named system 1 and system 2
system 1 thinking is your brain working
unconsciously and thank goodness it does
because that regulates heartbeat and
breathing and all the biological
functions that go on your body that
happened largely and almost exclusively
unconsciously system 2 is what
neuroscientists call conscious thought
that's what we may be aware of and both
of those types of thinking generate
responses now a neuroscientist friend
David Eagleman characterizes what goes
on in your brain is something like this
which is a picture of the British
Parliament and if you've ever watched it
on TV you see one side vociferously
arguing with the other side back and
forth seemingly to no decision or no
endpoint and that's really what goes on
in our brain between our unconscious
thoughts and our conscious thought today
we're going to focus on what happens in
the conscious side of your thinking and
a research scientist by the name of
Keith Stanovich at the University of
Toronto has has defined system to
thinking as type 1 and type 2 because
type 1 thinking algorithmic thinking and
algorithmic thinking is a process of
thinking where we apply what we already
know in a systematic and regular basis
it's very important to cognitive
processing because if we had two
reconsent relies every move of every day
our lives would be torturous so our
brain take shortcuts it creates frames
and it creates algorithms and it
reapplies them and from that comes a
response however every so often we
encounter something that doesn't match
one of our pre-existing frames and it
kicks us out of algorithmic thinking
into what he calls type 2 or reflective
thinking this is a process where we
uptake information into our working
memory hippocampus amygdala DES we use
lots of different systems in our brain
and we simulate potential responses and
then ultimately we choose a response and
it's this articulation between type 1
algorithmic
and type 2 reflective thinking that
really begins to define what we do with
design thinking the first perspective
would like to talk about deals with work
and empathy and defining what the design
problem is and it has to do with framing
Erving Goffman in the early 70s
identified this as a concept and what it
is is it's a schema of interpretation a
collection of experiences memories
stereotypes that we use to filter all
the input that comes comes through to us
you're undoubtedly familiar with the
picture in the lower left hand corner
which framed one way looks like an
attractive young woman turned away from
the viewer and framed another way looks
like an older woman looking down this
this picture was actually drawn in the
late 1800s and it's been studied quite
extensively and your brain will frame
that in one of two ways largely
dependent on who you are not
surprisingly men tend to frame it as a
young woman women tend to frame it as an
older woman in that context but it's
your brain creating a frame around that
picture that is algorithmic thinking
that system one thinking and what we
need to do as designers is to learn
first of all that that frame exists then
find a way to break that frame apart and
then reassemble that frame in a
different sort of way and that's the
process of reflective thinking and
simulation and along the way as you
might imagine there are many behavioral
and even cognitive speedbumps have it
the way you've always done it is a big
one but fear fear of change and fear of
differences the environment plays a
significant role in how you frame
problems and then finally group dynamics
what the people around you are saying
and doing provide those kinds of
problems what we do at the at the
d.school is we look at various
techniques that help people learn to not
only identify the frames are in but
adopt new frames things like picking a
beginner's mindset learning something
new from the very beginning or
practicing ethnography digging deeply
into the behaviors that a potential
consumer might be involved in personas
is something we use with young
engineering students where we actually
have them draw pictures of and write
descriptions of their potential end user
as a way to really understand what's
driving them and then ultimately create
new frames around what a potential
problem is the well here let's stop
right here because I'd like to ask a
question about framing and your ability
to reframe in the marketplace so as you
think about problems problems you face
how difficult do you find it for you and
your team to reframe those problems so
I'll turn over to Stacy and she'll
conduct the poll well there it is about
two-thirds of you maybe even hire say
it's somewhat difficult we can change
what we can change slowly and I would
say from a neurological perspective
that's absolutely correct we are wired
not to change we are wired to remain to
practice algorithmic thinking but with
help and perspective in the right
environment we can change and many of us
wish we could change faster in that way
and that's what that's really what
learning and training is all about is
helping us acquire the skill of being
able to reframe in a different sort of
way okay go to the next slide again back
to the design thinking process we've
talked about framing now let's talk
about risk risk is something that
cognitive neuroscience spent a lot of
time thinking about particularly in the
context of economics as people make
risky or less risky choices as they
relate to to economics it's important
for us to distinguish first of all that
there are different kinds of risks and
in this case particularly risk in the
context of ambiguity we know as human
beings that the choices we make lead to
specific outcomes and sometimes those
outcomes are good and some kind of
sometimes they're bad and as our brain
processes
it really processes two kinds of risk
the first is what we will call just risk
and that's where the rules and the
probability of an outcome are well known
well sensed or well understood and games
of chance gambling games are an example
of that our brain processes that in one
sort of way there are other kinds of
risky problems we come up against which
are called ambiguous problems that's
where the rules and the probabilities of
the outcome are unknown the picture on
the lower right hand side is a picture
of the Spanish influenza virus and what
what that's indicative of is when
situations like a pandemic occur don't
really know how how they spread where
they'll spread and what the implications
of them of a virus like that might be
and that's really an ambiguous problem
in the design world that's been defined
as something called a wicked problem
where essentially the parameters of the
problem are not understood well enough
to where you can develop any kind of
solution with predictability as it turns
out the brain processes this in very
different sorts of ways a risk which
we'll say we'll call deductive reasoning
where a equals B B equals C and
therefore a equals C risk is often
calculated in the cortex the prefrontal
cortex specifically and depending on the
type of problem you're solving it will
be done asymmetrically the right side or
left side in that kind of context
ambiguity on the other hand is often
processed in a very different kind of
place it's processed in the--in the
inner brain the limbic system and brain
systems like the amygdala the orbital
frontal cortex and the striatal system
which is a reward based system will
often be recruited as you sort through
ambiguous problems said another way a
simpler way is that with ambiguity
emotions play a much more significant
role in the process than they do with
let's say risky decisions or deductive
decisions so in the world of design
fine what we find is that most of the
problems are ambiguous problems you
don't have an obvious or logical
solution to them so emotions and
understanding emotions becomes an
important part of regulating the risk
and the definition of ambiguity in that
process so how do we deal with that and
let's say the ideation stage again
there's lots of speed bumps given the
fact that emotions are involved habit
and fear are important contributors as
well as the environment and group
dynamics and some of the techniques that
we practice our things like stoking
which is a way of connecting your mind
and body together in in terms of coming
in contact with your emotions and the
way in which you you choose and think we
have techniques where we can impose a
constraint so you can only use for
example your right hand or you can only
use your hearing to solve a particular
problem as a way to understand how you
might get in touch with difficult to
define and ambiguous problems we also
use an interesting feedback technique
called I like I wish and what if this is
important because as feedback is
provided it takes the negative aspects
out of it so rather than criticizing
someone's idea for what it lacks you
criticize someone's idea for what you
like in it you frame how it might be
made better as something you wish for
and then you offer suggestions in the
context of what if that simple little
tool changes the dynamics of
conversations around ideas in a way that
takes things from being scary and
ambiguous to more easily understood and
risky so let's ask a question now what
describes the risk tolerant tolerance of
your innovation environment of your
innovation team do you feel like you
live in a and a risk encouraging oral or
a risk-averse world
well most people are moving towards a
risk accepting world and what I would
say is that this is a bit of a trick
question
because if it is risky in other words if
you know the parameters if you know the
probabilities if you have a good chance
of estimating success or failure then
you're living in a risky world and most
businesses most innovation teams feel
good about accepting a risk under that
and under that requirement the problem
is many of the design challenges we face
are ambiguous you can't calculate a risk
associated with it and so that question
unfortunately is in here because most
people are actually having thought about
risk in terms of risk and ambiguity the
way you might which is how do you deal
with a situation where you really don't
know what any outcome might lead to and
how do you take those apart and therein
lies the challenge with which design ok
last but not least let's turn to the
third section that neuroscientists are
interested in and that's choice how we
choose and in this case it's how you
choose the idea and then how you build a
prototype and learn from that prototype
to drive it forward again as we talk
about the choices you make lead to an
outcome it's either good or bad and
we've learned a lot of this from our
distant ancestors and in fact I'll draw
your attention to an interesting study
about the orochon people who are a
tribal hunting culture in eastern
Siberia most of us today don't hunt
we don't go out in the woods and shoot
an animal however that is encoded in our
DNA it's encoded in our thought
processes because it was the way in
which we survived for hundreds of
thousands if not millions of years and
so the way in which we process hunting
expressed as Tim in golden in his book
called lines the way we think about this
is perhaps through lines and if you
think about a hunter they start in a
village and somewhere out there is the
target are reindeer where exactly that
is you may not know but you might know
the general area and the hunt ends up
looking like a line like this and in
this context you can tell because I told
you it's hunting is that it's not
wandering because at every step along
the way the hunter is sensing and
they're looking that they're in a sense
making choices and decisions about where
the actual goal might be and then of
course once the once the hunt is
concluded
the objective is to bring the the
reindeer back to the village as soon as
possible
and so these are two very distinctive
activities that we as human beings are
comfortable with and in gold calls one
of them wayfinding and it calls the
other one transport the issue in today's
world particularly in innovation world
is that we're much better at
transporting than we are wayfinding our
brain and in fact our reward structures
are all about transporting because this
isn't until you get the reindeer back to
the village that you actually achieve
the benefit of the hunt so the benefit
comes at the end of the transporting
phase and we are very good at
prosecuting that and understanding that
we're not so good at way finding because
wayfinding is full of lots of
uncertainty risk and ambiguity and
particularly in companies if you were to
take the take the position of I want to
spend some time just wandering
oftentimes people might consider that
wasteful not a good use of talent
another way of thinking about choices in
the context of wayfinding and
transporting is in terms of mindset a
convergent mindset and a divergent
mindset a GP guildford an American
psychologist coined this term in the
1950s as two ways in which you think two
ways in which you provide what he calls
mental production in a convergent mode
you're looking for a single best
solution to a problem and in a divergent
mode you're looking for a variety of
solutions to a problem and what we
we've actually done work with this in
our lab and what we find is that people
who have a preference for convergent
mindsets are interested in facts in fact
in a conversation with people about new
product development they will trade
facts over questions meaning they will
talk more about the facts and after the
conversation will rate the facts more
highly then people of a divergent
mindset and people in a divergent
mindset have a similar predisposition
towards questions they like questions
they introduce questions and after the
conversation they rate the questions
that were asked as being more important
to the solution than the facts and if
you think about it facts tend to close
down options because of factors of fact
and questions tend to open up problem
spaces or even shift problem spaces and
what we're finding is that people have
preferences for each of these kinds of
thinking the challenge we all face and
is that we must do both and we do do
both as as human beings but in a design
context when you start with a problem
you go through a period of diversion and
then ultimately have to converge because
you need to get something done so in all
of us is the ability to diverge and
converge the trick and the challenge of
course is to choose when to switch when
to go from a divergent mode to a
converging ode and of course as you're
going through a project you have many
periods of divergence and convergence as
you move through each one of those areas
so there's a chance for conflict between
divergent thinkers and convergent
thinkers in each area and a lot of this
has to do with the ability that people
have to shift between convergent and
divergent thinking and then of course as
I mentioned timing when is the right
time to stop diverging and begin
converging or stop converging and begin
diverging in the way we work this out in
design thinking is with the concept of
prototyping and testing prototyping and
building a prototype is a way to
simultaneously diverge and ultimately
converge on one design and it testing is
a way to verify it and essentially
kick-start the divergent process again
this is an example if you will of one of
our classes emmy 3:10 where students
will work on the development of a
kershel product and over the course of a
three of the three quarter experience
they'll develop nine different
prototypes that express this one idea
and it starts from an experienced
prototype that can be as open and
flexible as you might imagine all the
way up to the last prototype they build
in May is a reference prototype
something that can actually be produced
or scaled the challenge with prototyping
if you will in companies is that it
faces several speed bumps first of all
is habit we don't build prototypes we
build final solutions a big one is fear
failure prototypes by their very nature
or design to fail and because they do in
an environment that doesn't value
failure they can be fear inducing and so
people don't build prototypes there's
also a skill to building prototypes you
have to be comfortable doing things that
are less than perfect and some people
don't feel comfortable doing that and
then finally in a group dynamic context
prototypes can be difficult because
everyone might have a different idea and
it puts extra emphasis on how you
resolve conflicts over over where you go
in the d.school
several kinds of prototyping are taught
some of them you may be familiar with
others not the low-resolution
prototyping is one of the first steps
it's prototype being done with simple
materials you'd find in a grade school
but it helps people take an idea from
actually a number of synaptic
inflections to something physical even
if it isn't perfect Wizard of Oz
prototyping is is a type of prototype
where to the user it looks finished but
behind the scenes it's anything but you
know it's pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain
but it gives you a way to ultimately
understand how the user or the consumer
of your product might react to it
without the work of building the
infrastructure to deliver it perhaps the
most interesting prototype is something
we we do called a dark-horse prototype
it is the hardest for our
students to do and it's hard it's the
hardest for executives who come and work
with us to do and that is the prototype
that takes an oblique move away from a
solution it takes one of the ideas that
likely won't work RIT from a risk
perspective definitely wouldn't work but
if it did work would change the dynamics
of the answer completely and then
building that prototype out ultimately
it fails but almost always some learning
from that experience goes back into the
final prototype so prototyping is a big
part of the culture here and testing the
prototype is is important as well and it
forms the basis of how you make choices
in a design context so what I'd like to
understand is as you think about your
own innovation team would you think of
them as being mostly convergent thinkers
mostly divergent thinkers or a good mix
of both I'm going to give you a little
more time to answer this because I am
personally really interested well these
results actually align with our own
research here most people in the
business world are convergent thinkers
as they should be because they're valued
and rewarded for delivering results and
convergent thinking most directly
delivers results and that's the
environment we work in the challenge is
to get people to embrace divergent
thinking and then figure out a way to
manage or pivot if you will between
convergent and divergent thinking and
that's really what what's the essence of
sparking innovation on a team and that
brings you to the the title which is
pivot thinking and the ability to shift
between difference and sometimes
opposing problem solution possibilities
as you've seen in this talk you see the
possibility for much of this to be in
opposition algorithmic thinking versus
reflective thinking a frame having a
pre-existing frame versus reframing risk
assessment for
ambiguity tolerance are in opposition to
each other convergent thinking and
divergent thinking even if something as
simple as facts and questions stand in
opposition to each other in many cases
these behaviors use different neural
systems they recruit different regions
of the brain as you work through it and
the ability to switch between those two
pivot between those is what the
defines as we call it vivid thinking and
in the end what we would like to think
is really the heart of what is designed
thinking it's knowing both sides and
being able to more or less seamlessly
shift between those sides that brings me
to the end of my talk here which is the
thinking behind design thinking and you
can see in our tool chest there are lots
of different experiences that explore
the process of design thinking through a
lens of neuroscience a framing of risk
versus ambiguity and of choice in this
process so at this point I'm more or
less done I could open it up to
questions yeah you know I've actually
I'd like to join the conversation
well I'm sorry I do have because this is
the time to ask this question
well I based on what you have heard here
do you think you would end it this by
the way is the Net Promoter question so
we're really interested in you know how
likely are you to recommend the content
of what you've heard today in the
context of innovation to one of your
friends or colleagues how interested are
you in this and how much would you like
to learn more about it give people a
chance to look for that and while people
are answering that question let me
introduce myself
my name is Bill Burnett I'm the
executive director of the design program
at Stanford both an undergraduate and
graduate program in design and a member
of the D School where Mark and I both
teach and I wanted to ask a couple of
questions mark if I could because
there's a lot of interesting stuff you
know in your presentation but I really
want to kind of pull back
a little bit and see if we can tease out
some of the things that might be the
most valuable I know you've done a lot
of research yourself on the idea of
convergent and divergent thinkers and
what's a good combination for a team we
noticed that a lot of people said
there's mostly convergent thinkers of my
in my organization what is the research
tell us what is your opinion on what's a
good mix for a team that's really trying
to do innovative work
should they be mostly convergent mostly
divergent a mix of both and how do you
handle the conflict in mixing teams like
that well we we have that we have
studied this extensively and there are
some very interesting perspectives I
give you the first perspective is that
everyone's profile their preference
between convergent and divergent as well
as other issues is unique it's really as
unique as a fingerprint and that you
should feel good about your your own
preferences regardless of where you
start out the second point that's
important to incorporate is that people
as they as they think about this need to
understand their own biases their own
frames the frames that they bring to
bear the mistake that almost everyone
makes particularly the students we teach
is the belief that they are that
everyone else on the team is exactly
like them and in fact that isn't true at
all what you find out is that as you
understand the people on your team
they're just as unique as you are some
people are like you and some people are
different we also know from our research
is that people of various calm functions
within a company bring what we call
typical skillsets to bear so for example
we find that engineers are mostly
convergent thinkers although not not
exclusively but finance people tend to
be conversion thinkers and your FAC
shirring people tend to be convergent
thinkers on the flip side folks that do
marketing sales HR they may bring more
divergent skills to bear and so that as
we use the
the metaphor of a new products
development team where multifunctional
people are sitting around the table
there's a good bet that people will be
bringing very different skills to bear
on the process and and here's what's
surprising I would like to tell you that
oh yes a good mix of skills makes for a
better team but unfortunately it's not
that simple as we as we've studied it
the first issue is you have to really
understand the problem you're trying to
solve if you're trying to solve an
inherently convergent problem one that
really demands a unique solution like
the strength of a bridge or whether the
wings will stay on the new Airbus you
really want to convergent group of
people to be thinking about that for the
most part and get to the single best
answer for that so there are there are
problems that necessarily lend
themselves to a specific skill set but
generally speaking for ambiguous
problems or broader describe problems
having a mix of people in a team is
actually a good thing and what we found
is that there are two characteristics to
really making a design team whose
tackling ambiguous problems work the
first is a mix of skills on the team
between convergent-divergent but the
second is a is a term called if you will
social connect ability which is your
ability to understand and interpret
other people on your team and at the
same time internalize those differences
and not be annoyed but instead be be
intrigued and interested in those
differences and for people who have this
what we call social sensitivity skill
and teams actually teams if you can
measure that skill amongst everyone on
the team and get a total measure teams
that have a higher rating in social
sensitivity almost universally do better
on any skill or any kind of design tasks
we put in front of them so that that
helped you get a sense for how you think
about that yeah very much so um and I
think you know you're you're right in
saying that most of us think everybody's
like us but in fact that's not true if I
wanted to find out am i more convergent
or divergent thinker just as a point of
reference for myself so that I could
bring my best self to a team are there
assessment tools that I could use to
figure that out oh sure
oh sure in fact we use assessment tools
we can't put everyone in an fMRI scanner
and we're expensive and very slow and so
that is useful for making kind of
specific scientific kinds of discoveries
broadly we we rely on a series of what
we'll call psychometric instruments one
of the primary ones is something called
the Neo five-factor design which has
five factors that have been correlated
with pretty much most of everyone's
personality and what we find is that the
the factors of openness and in
compliance those two of the five factors
really speak a lot towards convergent
and divergent divergent people tend to
be higher and you open a scale
convergent people tend to be higher on
the compliance scale we also use an
instrument quite extensively called a
Herrmann brain dominance indicator in
this case the a factor the analytic
factor tends to be more conversion and
the D factor the innovative or creative
factor tends to be more divergent we've
also looked at the Curtin adaptive
innovative index or ke AI and in that
index innovators tend to be more
divergent adapters tend to be more
convergent again none of those skills
are better or worse they're certainly
situational but but we can use a series
of psychometric instruments commonly
used psychometric instruments it's
really get a sense for whether and where
an individual is and then ultimately
where a team is and not context yeah
it's great I think well make sure that
people that we cite those references for
folks when they download the webinar I
want to move to one other thing that you
talked about which it seems to be very
important in sign
and I know we do a lot of this at the Z
school it's one of our primary methods
of discovery and innovation and that's
prototyping you know we let's just as
you mentioned we used a lot of different
kind of prototyping lots of low
resolution prototyping where we leave
out a lot of details and just sort of
explore you know one or two issues of
the idea and I love the term Wizard of
Oz prototyping and Dark Horse
prototyping it seems to it seems to me
the way you describe it the prototyping
is really more about asking good
questions and it is about you know
building models of answers I think when
I speak with teams in product
development R&D particularly Rd teams
they think of a prototype as being the
model of the thing they're going to
build right or the model of the thing
they're going to propose this sounds
like a very different definition can you
talk to that a little bit it is clearly
one of the prototypes you build is what
we call the reference model prototype
which is the very last prototype and
that's something that's valuable as you
think about manufacturing and scaling
but there are many prototype options
before you get to that point interesting
about dealing with both students and
executives what we find out is that your
willingness to prototype is all almost
inversely correlated with your age
meaning the younger you are the more
willing you are to pick up play-doh and
pipe cleaners and scissors and tape and
build something and the older the you
are the more reluctant you are to do
that and yet that skill that ability to
take synaptic energy an idea and turn it
into something physical and tangible is
the is that the kind of building blocks
a very basic building block of design
thinking and and and you can be on-ramp
onto that literally is as easy as
working with marshmallows and dry
spaghetti strands all the way up to
building things out of plywood that
ultimately you're going to make out of
cast aluminum
so there are there's a whole scalable
process for learning they build
prototypes but in the in the bottom of
it is the same neurological underpinning
is that you need to take the ideas you
have in your head the thoughts and
feelings you have in your head and make
them tangible and real in some sort of
way and that's that's the bedrock of
prototyping and Design Thinking yeah I'm
glad you mentioned you know so the
emotional you know the gut feelings you
have in another seminar we did we talked
about some of Daniel Goleman's
researched and Dolman Sakai sort of
invented the notion of emotional
intelligence right he talked about a
lawyer who had a brain tumor in a
certain part of his brain and process of
removing that tune of tumor they
disconnected his prefrontal cortex from
areas in his limbic system particularly
the amygdala and basal ganglia and the
lawyer could no longer make decisions
right
he was absolutely paid he could he was
his IQ tested the same his his all of
his other cognitive bilities were as
good or better still appeals every now
but because he's lost the ability to
valence as Goldman calls it valence his
decisions with an emotional component he
couldn't make even the simplest
decisions he couldn't decide when to
have the next appointment with his
doctor he couldn't decide you know
whether he was going to have you know
pizza or Chinese food tonight he lost
his job his wife left him he ended up
living in his brother
brother's house and spare bedroom and
what they discovered in that particular
case men looking deeper is parts of your
brain that control the emotional
response amygdala limbic system basal
ganglia which are not connected to the
parts of your brain which control speech
and and sort of logic inform you of the
emotional valence of Velen severe
decisions in different ways
literally in unconscious ways that
cannot be put into words in fact their
basal ganglia is connected directly to
your some
to your gut so parts of gut feelings are
literally the parts of your brain that
process emotion giving you information
but information in a way that you know
it's kind of unusual and it's said more
of a feeling or our sense literally I
got feeling so I think I think it's
really critical to understand that part
of what we do in design thinking and
innovation is invoke the emotional side
you know the equation is why we start
with empathy it's why we do a deep dive
on the human need so why we use
interviews and stories to kind of you
know flesh out what the real problem is
because at the end of the day any good
and any good designer engineering team
is probably equally as good at solving a
problem as any other team if you've got
smart people in your company and you say
here's the problem once you solve and
you have enough convergent divergent
thinkers and good tools you'll come up
with a good solution the problem we see
over and over again is you solve the
wrong problem right so it's all about
your problem finding were you really
wrong yeah yeah well you're really
unlock innovation is in the reframing or
problem finding section of the process
and that starts with empathy which
engages you know kind of the emotional
intelligence as well as the facts
figures you know now one of those that
can be measured and one of the basic
emotions we study is fear and fear of
failure of course is one that one that
stands in the way of doing prototyping
there's a part of the brain called the
orbital frontal cortex which sits sort
of right under the cortex right and in
front of the limbic system and and we
are particularly interested in that
because we think that structure might
form a mediating process between
decisions that are fear-based and
decisions that are at a risk based
analytically based and that your brain
uses that region as a way to decide
essentially how am I going to solve this
am I going to solve it as a risky
problem right now the probabilities am I
going to solve it as an ambiguous
problem where I need to engage emotion
and having people be able to understand
how those two systems are triggered and
how to work within those two systems we
think from a neurological standpoint
will help people make
better design decisions so we'll be
hearing more about the orbital frontal
cortex as time goes on but that's the
that we were learning that that may be
the key regulator is to how you make
choices and move oh yeah and in another
piece of research and then I think we'll
have to wrap up and move on but another
piece of research in a book called
iconoclast which is by Gregory Berns
who's a neuroscientist the findings on
people who score high on psychometrics
evaluative tests on creativity or
openness one of the things that seems to
be different from them than other people
is that they have a unusually low fear
response to novelty you know when put in
a brain scanner and shown something
they've never seen before something
unusual we have evolved and logically so
we've evolved to backup from enough
novelty to four hour flight or fight
response to turn on priming to low to
fire up and and for us to be cautious of
novel things novel things could jump out
of the woods Anita's novel things could
be dangerous it looks like people who
rate highly on creativity tests are kind
of broken in that regard they they don't
have a very high purist monster novelty
another way of looking at this in other
word we use for that is called curiosity
well yeah followed by a mad George Lane
did some really interesting research in
the 60s and 70s where he took JP gophers
creativity test you know what are how
many things can you do with a brick or
how many things can you do with a
paperclip and he gave it to a range of
subjects ranging from sort of
preschoolers all the way up to people in
their 40s and they just simply counted
how many things you could come up with
and it turns out that there is an expert
level of this and if you're sort of
under six years old
you score in the expert level category
kind of 90% of the time and if you're
over thirty years old you score in the
expert area sort of ten percent of the
time and the reason is is they went back
and went through it is that when you're
younger you have less can be placed less
constraints on on things so for example
how many things can you do with a
paperclip well if it was made out of
marshmallow
if it was 200 feet tall you could
envision doing a lot of different things
that someone who's six years old could
imagine because they don't have the
frames that limit their thinking their
constraints that limit their thinking
whereas when you're older you say well
paperclips aren't made of marshmallow
they're not 200 feet tall so I can hold
paper together with them and there you
are living within your frame the frame
that served you very well by the way up
until that point but it's not helping
you essentially identify new and and
potentially useful passive design okay
well I think we're going to run out of
time very quickly and we've got a few
things to wrap up with so thank you very
much mark I appreciate that I'm going to
turn it over now to Carissa thanks Bill
and just to let folks know we have one
or two questions that we'll be answering
at the end and feel free to be asking
questions online we'll be we'll be
staying in the Live Meeting and
answering all those questions near the
end here so just to want to give you a
brief overview of the Stanford center
for professional development we've been
delivering education to industry for
over 40 years and we have reasonable
experience creating educational programs
to address the career long learning
needs of professionals managers and
executives and industry we at Stanford
are pleased to be offering the
Innovation Master Series in partnership
with faculty like Mark and bill for
three days senior faculty will lead you
through frameworks that lead to
innovation and strategic leadership
pioneered by the Design Group and the
d.school at Stanford it's a very
hands-on workshop while you'll learn the
problem-solving tools and techniques
that come out of those the research at
the Design Group in the d.school
we designed this program for managers
business leaders and decision-makers
faced with a daunting task of retooling
and revitalizing their enterprises and
here you can get a sense of who might
benefit from attending we created the
series because we've been hearing how
organizations struggle to make
innovation routine for quite some time
in today's business environment
companies continue to be challenged to
implement more projects with fewer
resources here you can see some of the
key takeaways that can help you navigate
tomorrow's business challenges and
really impact the long-term success of
your organization's truly one of the
most unique aspects of those series is
that you will get the opportunity to
engage with a who's-who lineup of
faculty from the Stanford Design Group
in the d.school they've pioneered design
thinking and to solve today's wicked
problems by using the techniques that
you heard about from from mark and and
bill today and I just want to take one
moment to conduct a poll here we'd
really appreciate your feedback on this
if you could give us a sense of your
interest level and the innovation master
series and we'll just leave that open
while we answer one or two more
questions that have come in from some of
the participants in the webinar so you
mark you mentioned that social
sensitivity is something that is really
important for teams to be aware of and
thinking about is there a test or a way
to measure that that exists there are uh
it's it there are a couple of research
papers that have been written on the
subject that help understand what are
the what are the psychological dynamics
of it it is not a a single measure and
by the way I want to correct the
language test and none of these things
are tests in the sense that there's a
right answer or a wrong answer
we refer to them as instruments because
they measure and they measure where you
are on a particular scale so there are
several instruments that measure it for
example the HPD I see factor is a good
measure of it we've also found that some
combination some unique combinations of
the of
- I'm flanking on it Freud's the EMT GA
what I pay my respects at myers-briggs
I'm sorry some some unique combinations
of that we've got a researcher here it's
been working on what combinations of
those four factors and myers-briggs
makes a different difference in that
area and then there are some very simple
and purposeful instruments that measure
in a sense how people connect with each
other in a social sense that have been
useful as measures of it so there there
are several ways in which you can
measure but I think once you know that
it's the ability to understand to read
other people and then to use that
knowledge in a productive sort of way
that just that knowledge goes a long way
towards helping people do a better job
of that thank you that's great and and
as we mentioned we'll be distributing
some of these these tools for folks
after the webinar if you could also talk
a little bit about how how do you break
down the fear of failure within
organizations or teams how do you
approach that
well it's interesting the the first way
will scare the heck out of you if you're
already afraid is and that is to just
fail one of the in a semi 310 class one
of the very first exercises we do is we
have students build paper bicycles and
then we put them through a testing
process that is designed to have them
fail usually it involves water paper
don't mix and it's amazing how when they
begin this they're their whole goal is
to build a bike that doesn't fail and in
the end they end up finding that the
bikes that failed in the most
spectacular ways well the ones that were
most interesting and where they learn
the most from and so actually the best
way to deal with failure is to fail and
- yeah we do exactly the same thing in
the entry-level engineering class that
every mechanical engineer product design
engineer at Stanford has to take called
Emmy 101 visual thinking we literally
give them problems for which there are
no answer
we don't tell them that up front of
course because it wouldn't be as much
fun you have to you have to desensitize
yourself personally and then as an
organization to this fear of failure if
you are afraid to fail you will not
innovate it's not possible because
innovation involves failure now I'm not
saying failure in the marketplace you
don't take you don't take your failures
all the way to you know large scale you
know product introductions but if you
are not explore look look at the best
model we have for innovation potentially
in the capital society as the venture
capital model in the venture capital
model they invest a billion dollars in a
hundred companies and five of them
succeed and they're considered you know
really smart people for that kind of
investment ratio so if you believe that
the venture capital model succeeds and
believe it in your organization actually
if you act like a venture capitalist you
start many many projects you prototype
with a very low resolution in a very low
cost you provoke lots and lots of
failures you reward people who fail for
their energy effort and innovation and
you you know sift through timid venture
capitalists don't invest you know in a
seer and in and around and failed
companies and the point is to fail early
fail often fail cheap I know at P&G
nobody wants to have on the resume here
those seven things I failed at but our
CEO at the time started award the
failure award and it was about the most
interesting and unusual failure that
occurred throughout the year and it
wasn't usually on some huge project that
was embarrassing and financial reg
bunting it was on some startup project
some interesting test idea that the
failure of the product actually
springboard it into new ideas and new
approaches having a culture that
encourages fail early fail often fail
cheap is the way in which you learn to
prototype and succeed great and so one
final question
how do you approach innovating and
changing business processes in law and
large urging organizations as opposed to
creating a new product to sell is there
a difference well there is there isn't I
mean obviously services the way we think
about the world between products and
services has many differences in terms
of their ability to or how you how you
actually go from idea to marketplace but
there are also many similarities and the
idea of being able to identify empathize
what the what the customer wants ID
eight potential solutions and to develop
prototyping that it satisfies those
solutions is inherent to services as
much as it is products in fact I
mentioned earlier the Wizard of Oz
prototype that is largely used in
software prototyping where you will
develop user interface that is that
tests what the user sees in the context
of software but all the coding work that
goes on behind it the really heavy duty
lifting and moving isn't there in fact
some cases it's actually manipulated by
humans behind the scenes just to give
the feel for what the interface would
look like you can still do prototyping
in a service environment and the basic
principles of design thinking apply just
as much to services as they do to
products great thank you so much I want
to just one final thank you to mark and
Bill and thank everyone for joining us
today we do plan to make a video this
presentation available and we will be
sending out an email to announce it to
everyone when that's ready and s where
we'll be including some of these tools
for you if again if you'd like to print
out a PDF of today's presentation please
select the handouts icon in the top
navigation bar and click the file that
you'd like to download there are several
there and click download and thank you
so much and we'll be remaining online
until all the questions in the queue
have been answered thanks so much